hey youtubers it's Charlie and here's
the details on my game of thrones show
that i'll be doing in addition to the
videos i'll be doing for each episode
it's called kill list and as the name
implies it's all about the deaths on the
show just as a way to reward you guys
for being so awesome and being so
engaged with the videos I do every week
I wanted to start doing a new show there
would be a lot of fun and give you guys
a chance to win some cool free stuff so
what's going to happen when Game of
Thrones comes back is I'm going to post
my normal review videos right after the
episodes air then the next day I'm
actually going to post a breakdown of
all the people that died during the
episode and whoever guesses the correct
order in which people die will win a
prize just to make it a little bit
easier and a little bit more fun you
don't have to guess people's names you
just have to guess which house they
belong to or organizations that can be
like Lannisters gold cloaks even a stark
so here's a much more detailed
explanation of how everything's going to
work number one for example the week
before season 4 episode 1 airs I'll post
a game of thrones kill list video with
my predictions on who's going to die
during the episode 2 you guys will post
your predictions in the comments of that
video the order you might guess might go
like House Lannister gold cloak night's
watchman random peasant does rocky etc 3
after episode 1 airs I'll post a
breakdown of who actually died and
announced the winner so each week you'll
be predicting who will die and in what
order in next week's episode so in my
episode 2 video you'll actually be
guessing the order for episode 3 and so
on number four the rules you have to be
18 or have your parents permission
winners will get a random game of
thrones themed prize chosen by me
probably a Funko pop figure in case no
one gets the kills or the order of the
desk right I'll just pick whoever came
the closest so if you got the names out
of order but you guess the order of the
desk by house correctly you can still
win and don't worry you don't have to
guess every single death in the episode
you do have to be a subscriber and you
can only win once during the season
trolls will be automatically
disqualified number 5 the prize for
guessing the correct kill order during
the finale will be extra special so if
you're still confused about how it's all
going to work I'm going to post to Game
of Thrones videos every week once the
show comes back the first video will be
my traditional review the second video
will be that results video with the
breakdown of the kill order don't worry
if you have any more questions about it
just ask me in the comments be sure to
subscribe
to participate if you're totally pumped
about the idea of a weekly game of
thrones contest and get even more
excited I'm going to do the exact same
thing for walking dead whenever it comes
back to because that shows just a little
bit different those killas videos will
also be different i'll post a separate
video explaining how that contest is
going to work later this week but it's
basically the exact same idea guess the
kill order see what happens collect
prices give high fives rinse repeat
right now click here for the Mega Game
of Thrones Martell video that I just
posted and click here for my latest
Walking Dead video thank you so much for
being awesome I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives